c'est l'heure du second débat de ce sens
public consacré ce soir à la loi
immigration que le gouvernement ve voir
adopter avant la fin de l'année selon le
ministre de l'Intérieur ce nouveau texte
aurait permis d'expulser le terroriste
assassin du professeur de lettres
Dominique Bernard don les obsès vous en
parliez tout à l'heure ont été célébré
ce matin à haras que contient le texte
qui doit être examiné à partir du 6
novembre au Sénat les détails avec
Cécile Sixou le texte immigration un
cass-etête pour géralde Darmanin avant
même son examen au Parlement le ministre
le sait il ne pourra pas compter sur les
alr dont il a besoin pour avoir une
majorité s'il ne retire pas l'article 3
celui-ci prévoit de régulariser les
sanspiers dans les métiers en tension il
y a des articles sur lequels nous ne
lâcherons pas c'est la régularisation
par le travail vous le savez ça c'est
des lignes rouges sur lesqueles nous ne
lâcherons pas une ligne rouge à droite
qui agace particulièrement les
centristes les partenaires DLR au Sénat
sont favorables à cette
il est important pour un seul article
qui devient totéique et qui mérite pas
autant d'ignominie euh qu'on puisse
trouver une solution très sincèrement
après ce qui s'est passé à haras après
ce qui s'est passé à Bruxelles quand on
voit la difficulté au Proche-Orient
s'arrêter sur un article comme celui-là
c'est vraiment pas au niveau de la
situation trouver un accord pourrait
vouloir dire sortir la mesure du texte
mais ce scénario c'est le groupe
Renaissance à l'assemblée qui le refuse
s'il ne l'est pas au Sénat nous le
réintroduirons à l'Assemblée nationale
là où il faut être très clair là il faut
c'est qu'il faut juger il faut juger les
étrangers pour ce qu'ils font et pas
pour ce qu'ils sont sans point de
convergence sur cet article le ministre
cherche à séduire autrement les LR il
leur donne des gages sur le côté fermeté
du texte et se dit prêt à revoir sa
copie s'il y a des propositions
supplémentaires d'où qu'il viennent qui
permettront à n'importe quel moment et
conformément à ce que le gouvernement
essaie de faire depuis le début de
l'élection du président de la République
c'est-à-dire avoir la
fermeté contre tous ceux qui veulent
toucher les valeurs françaises je
donnerai un avis favorable mais pas sûr
que les efforts de géralde Darmanin ne
suffisent les groupes LR du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée ont inscrit une proposition
de loi concurrente dans leur niche
parlementaire les 7 et 12 décembre
prochains elle propose entre autre de
déroger au droit international sur les
questions migratoires ou encore
d'élargir leur référendum à la politique
d'immigration je vous présente tout de
suite les invités de ce débat dans sens
public Hervé Lebas bonsoir bons vous
êtes historien démographe directeur
d'études à l'École des hautes études en
sciences sociales et chercheurs émérite
à l'Institut national d'études
démographiques Rachel binaz bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste au service société du
magazine Marianne Jean-Sébastien Ferjou
bonsoir le fondateur le directeur
d'Atlantico Émilie zapalski évidemment
spécialiste en communication politique
éctorialist pour sens public est resté
euh à mes côtés euh Hervé leas c'est le
29e texte sur l'immigration depuis 1980
euh est-ce qu'il est indispensable
est-ce que la pression migratoire euh
augmente à ce point nonon sur la
pression migratoire euh non si on
regarde les les chiffres pour en revenir
en détail euh mais surtout je pense
qu'il n'est pas indispensable il est
indispensable pour le jeu politique pour
que les partis politiques prennent une
posture donc de ce point de vue-là il
joue un rôle mais si vous prenez depuis
une trentaine d'années vous regardez les
chiffres et puis vous vous demandez euh
est-ce qu'on peut distinguer le moment
où il y a une majorité de gauche ou une
majorité de droite dans l'évolution du
solde
migratoire c'est impossible autrement
dit
c'est dire c'est un peu des
gesticulations parce que très très vite
on se heurte à des impossibilités on va
sans doute en reparler notamment par
exemple la plus forte bien sûr c'est
pour l'exécution des des ordres de tirer
de quitter
oui parce que il y a la nécessité des
passeports consul des
euh l'autorisation par les consuls de
faire donc donc je pense qu'on est
plutôt dans un débat qui permet aux
politiques de s'affirmer en tant
politique parti par parti effectivement
le le contexte politique Rachel bignas
notamment la question de la reconduite à
la frontière d'individus potentiellement
dangereux qui peuvent être en situation
régulière d'ailleurs c'est c'est là qui
est le débat ça rend ce texte
particulièrement opportun est-ce que
vous diriez ça je dirais que de manière
générale en Europe il y a une crainte
parmi les pays dit d'accueil quant à
l'état des flux euh al je je vais pas
vous vous noyer sous sous les chiffres
mais par exemple en 2022 les frontières
de l'Union européenne ont été forcé par
plus d'un million de personnes 953000
environ d'entre elles ont fait une
demande d'asile donc à l'immigration
régulière traditionnelle regroupement
familial titre de travail s'ajoute
justement cette immigration de notamment
de de demandeurs d'asile cette crainte
là qu'elle soit justifiée ou non elle
est perceptible dans bon nombre de pays
pas seulement en France l'Allemagne par
par exemple récemment ben vient de
rétablir les contrôles aux frontières la
Suède se pose et s'est posé beaucoup de
questions quant à l'intégration quel est
l'état justement de l'intégration qui
est possible ou non dans dans son pays
donc le contexte est bien plus général
et bien plus large que ça il n'est pas
seulement français mais en effet vous
avez raison de le souligner à l'onne
justement de de ces événements tragiques
de ce notamment de ce ce dernier
attentat et bien on on voit on en
lumière les faiblesses de notre droit je
pense là directement à cet individu
russe mais d'origine tchenenne que la
franceouche in gouche pour être précis
exactement que la France ne pouvait
expulser éloigner au motif qu'il était
arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans sur le
territoire c'est l'un des éléments que
vous remettre en question dermanin par
ce projet de loi alors c'est intéressant
n nos confrères du Figaro ont commandé
un un sondage à l'Institut odoxa pour
évaluer ce que ce qu'attendent ou ce
qu'espèrent les Français d'un d'un
nouveau projet de loi immigration la
question c'est le projet de loi
immigration permettra-t-il de réduire la
menace du terrorisme islamiste la
réponse c'est non à 69 % Jean-Sébastien
Ferjou quand vous voyez ces chifr vous
dites quoi les Français sont sont
lucides finalement ils ont intégré ce
que vous n disiez quels que soient les
je vais reprendre vos mots les
gesticulations politique ça ça ne change
pas grand-chose ben sont quand même de
considération où il peut y avoir une
continuité mais profondément différente
la régulation des flux migratoires et le
terrorisme par ailleurs on a vu qu'il y
avait un terrorisme domestique de gens
qui peuvent être de nationalité
française ou déjà installé en France
depuis des années donc je pense qu'il
faut bien distinguer les enjeux Gérald
armanin a eu la tentation enfin n'a pas
eu seulement la tentation d'ailleurs à
exploiter un peu ce projet de loi en
disant que si cette loilà avait été en
vigueur il aurait été était possible
d'avoir expulsé le jeuningouche enfin
don dont on parlait tout à l'heure ce
qui est du reste assez contestable parce
que c'était déjà possible le problème
c'est que les magistrats n'ont pas
souhaité le faire vous savez commch
alors cé c'était 2014 toute la famille
aurait pu être être expulsé pu il y a eu
un mouvement des associations par
poli des recours en réalité ce qui
bloque bien souvent c'est d'une part la
volonté politique d'autre part ceux qui
sont là pour appliquer les droits h
pardon ce ne sont pas les lois en tant
que tel bien souvent mais ceux qui sont
là pour appliquer les lois même si
évidemment comme le soulignit racha tout
à l'heure quand on voit l'arrêt 2022 de
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui condamne la France pour avoir voulu
expulser enfin expulser et voulu
expulser de tchenchen en disant même
s'il représente un danger pour la vie de
la nation on ne peut pas soumettre des
individus à des conditions Barbar et
inhumaine oui parce
que en rentrant dans leur pays d'origine
ça les mettait en danger oui oui mais ce
qui signifie clairement que les
magistrats la Cour européenne des droits
de l'homme préfèrent la sécurité
d'étrangers dangereux qui assument
d'être dans un projet dangereux et qui
assume d'être dans un projet terroriste
et islamiste puisque c'était le cas des
deux tetchenînes en question plutôt que
la sécurité des citoyens quel que soient
leurs origines d'ailleurs qui vivent qui
vivent en France et ça de toute façon
aussi longtemps qu'on ne changera pas
l'état d'esprit la mentalité et pas
seulement de la classe politique pas
seulement de la magistrature mais
peut-être même de la société tout
entière rien ne changera et dans 5 ans
on en sera peut-être à la 47e 72e ou la
2083e loi sur l'immigration mais
effectivement ça n'aura pas changé grand
chose moi j'ai l'impression que dans ces
sujets il y a quand même beaucoup de
confusion on est obligé de le rappeler
comme vous l'avez fait attention
immigration terrorisme faut pas toujours
faire la main gamme comme
immigration mais là en l'occurrence
c'est l'argument l'argument du
gouvernement c'est de dire on peut pas
les expulser parce que c'est aurait pu
avoir les moyens d'expulser les
individus dangereux si la loi av je suis
d'accord mais je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup d' GAM comme vous l'avez dit
par exemple sur les flux migratoires on
a l'impression qu'il y a une submersion
migratoire et quand on revient à des
données enfin j'imagine vous on se rend
compte que c'est pas si tangible ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'on n'est jamais
sur de la matière un peu froide où on
peut réfléchir posément parce qu'on est
toujours dans dans cette et et dans des
ressentis et dans des ressentis
énormément comme dans la sécurité où il
y a des ressentis ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on peut on peut évidemment
traiter du terrorisme et vous l'avez dit
le terrorisme il peut être il peut être
aussi et on l'a vu totalement français
et se dire que notre état doit renforcer
ses actions pour se protéger de ça et ça
n'a rien à voir ou quelquefis à voir à
l'immigration
espmeité tangible sur les chiffres parce
qu'on peut avoir des raisonnements
absurd considérer ne regarder que
l'aspect juridique des choses est-ce que
vous avez ou non la nationalité
française et considérer que les seuls
immigrés sont ceux qui finalement
n'auraient pas la nationalité française
c'est totalement absurde si on le
regarde au fil du temps quand on regarde
le nombre de naissance qu'il y a
désormais en France chaque année par
rapport au nombre d'arrivées sur le
territoire ça donne quand même une idée
du fait qu'il se passe quelque chose et
notamment sur certains territoires par
exemple par exemple en scène sa oui mais
on connait les analyses de Monsieur
Lebras depuis longtemps s'oppose à celle
de Madame Trib beaucoup d'autres je su
plus près des chiffres que vous en tout
cas
alorszy je vous non je vais vous donner
des chiffres qui sont parfaitement
vérifiables sur cette question de des
immigrés la meilleure façon de voir
c'est de combien la population immigrée
augmente chaque année et ça comment
peut-on le faire on peut le faire parce
que il y a des enquête de recensement de
l'INC et c'est des grosses enquêtes
c'est pas loin de 10 millions de
personnes qui sont enquêtées chaque
année donc on a des chiffres assez sûr
vous pouvez aller sur le site de l'INC
je peux vous donner la référence ici et
vous verrez on a donc par nationalité
chaque année le nombre d'immigrés de
différentes
origines quand on regarde comment cela
évol ça existe depuis 2006 on voit que
en moyenne depuis 2006 la l'augmentation
de la population immigrée non européenne
est de 102000 personnes par an
exactement donc est-ce que ça a beaucoup
augmenté dans les années récente un
petit peu mais en fait très peu c'est de
l'ordre du de quelques milliè pour donc
il y a pas du tout une invasion j' je
regrette monsieur fergou vous allez
regarder ces chiffres là c'est pas de
savoir si mais non mais non là vous me
traitez de malhonnêé
vous je n'ai jamais parlé d' mais c'est
l'argument vous employez toujours
d'autorité pour faire per qui vous
monsieur le BR il y a des tas de
démographes qui interprèt les notion de
l vous le faites et je n'ai jamais parlé
d'vasion ge
gardez
Mor on va calmer le débat tout de suite
parce je n'ai jamais parlé d'invasion
mais c'est toujours le même argument de
Malon
inbat depuis 40 ans pour disalifier
quiconque n'est pas d'accord a jeis pas
parler plus fort que vous ça ne sert à
rien j'en suis convaincu dans un débat
voilà et on a entendu vos arguments à
l'un et à l'autre sur cette question
donc on va essayer d'avancer tout de
suite peut-être pour parler de des des
enjeux politiques Émilie je vous donne
la parole parce que il y a cette volonté
on a on a entendu dans dans vos
arguments aux uns et aux autres
effectivement les annonces de du
ministre de l'Intérieur il y a cette
volonté d'accélérer le calendrier dans
un contexte qui est quand même très
lourd et ben oui il faut dire que ce
contexte quelque part il aide le
ministre de l'Intérieur à avancer sur
des mesures un peu plus musclées
notamment pour s'assurer et on l'a dit
de pouvoir expulser des personnes
menaçantes pas la peine de rappeler que
tout comme l'auteur de l'assassinat de
Samuel pati l'assaillant de Dominique
Bernard est fiché s il était suivi par
les services de renseignement depuis la
fin du mois de juillet l'opinion elle
est évidemment en attente de fermeté et
on l'a bien vu avec les évolutions à la
hausse de la courbe de popularité de
Gabriel FAL suite à à l'interdiction de
la baaya à l'école les déclarations des
uns et des autres gerérald daranin en
tête montrent l'envie d'avancer sans sur
le sujet parfois sans grande nuance il
faut procéder je le cite à l'expulsion
systématique de tout étranger considéré
comme dangereux par les services de
renseignement c'est ce qu'il a déclaré
au lendemain de la mort du professeur
Daras on sent aussi la tentation du
gouvernement de satisfaire au passage
les républicains sur le projet de loi en
vue évidemment d'un vote au Parlement et
pas de 493 quitte à faire évoluer en
éclat l'équilibre de ce texte pour
rappel ce texte était formé en deux
parties un premier volet destiné à
régulariser des S papiers employés dans
les métiers en tension volet qui
pourrait diminuer comme pot de chagrin
et de l'autre côté un volet répressif
qui à l'inverse pourrait gonfler avec ce
contexte est-ce que dans ce contexte
émotionnel on va dire ça comme ça c'est
c'est raisonnable de mener ce ce projet
de loi de l'accélérer en tout cas en
tout cas c'est la question qu'a posé une
député de la majorité Caroline janvier
elle a dit cela avancer le projet de loi
est inapproprié au vu de contexte et de
la très forte émotion c'était dans un
entretien au Figaro publié hier elle
menace même de ne pas voter le texte si
se volilit sur le travail et la
régularisation des personnes qui
travaillent sur les métiers en tension
était amoindri alors on a commencé à en
parler cette nouvelle loi est-ce qu'elle
permettrait d'expulser des étrangers
juger dangereux c'est difficile parce
que comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure les
lois permettent déjà des choses qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire il faudrait pour
aller plus loin probablement contourner
les décisions de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ça a déjà été fait à
deux reprises en août 2022 pour expulser
des ressortissants tchenens en Russie
euh il faudrait aussi peut-être
caractériser davantage les grifs la
formulation récente de Gérald armanin
visant à expulser je le cite encore tous
les étrangers qui adhèrent à une
idéologie radicale c'est encore un peu
flou alors il a dit récemment que
c'était par exemple quand on avait on
détenait une photo de décapitation sur
ton téléphone mais c'est pas encore très
bien caractérisé bref il s'agirait de
décider à court terme un peu comme le
principe que Sarkozy faisait un fait
divers une loi mais au passage il
s'agirait aussi de renier notre État de
droit au détriment de nos valeurs
démocratiques et quelque part c'est
aussi le but des terroriste alors ça
c'est votre votre opinion je vous
propose de de creuser cette cette notion
de de valeur de ne pas respecter les
valeurs de la République d'adhérer à une
idéologie islamique et et d'entendre
pour ça et ensuite je donnerai la parole
aux uns et aux autres le porte-parole du
gouvernement Olivier
verrand le but il est de faire en sorte
que quand une personne étrangère dans
notre pays ne respecte pas les valeurs
de notre République par son comportement
par ses paroles mais en danger la
cohésion de la nation mais en danger les
valeurs républicaines n'adhère pas aux
valeurs qui sont les nôtres et y compris
d'ailleurs les valeurs d'accueil des
personnes qui on ont besoin lorsque
cette personne ne s'inscrit pas dans les
pas de la République que la République
ne soit pas contrainte de la conserver
sur sur son territoire Rachel bignas
est-ce que c'est pas trop flou pour être
applicable ben pour le moment oui il y a
pas de cadre juridique défini et en
effet ça relève plutôt de de la
communication néanmoins ça peut se
définir d'après vous oui oui ça peut
bien sûr ça peut se définir par exemple
la durée ça peut se traduire par une
durée en centre de rétention
administrative plus importante Géral
rmanin a appelé de ses vœux bah une
augmentation un passage à 18 mois de
durée en centre de rétention
administrative c'est centrre justement
dans lequel on retient les personnes
avant un un éloignement dans dans
l'idéal pour les forces de l'ordre
parfois parfois cela n' n'a pas lieu
bien nous en France la durée bien sûr
est est limitée elle était à 60 jours à
une époque elle est passée à 90 jours et
Gérald haranin aimerait que ce soit donc
18 mois notamment pour les étrangers en
situation irrégulière alors délinquant
délinquant fich s ça reste encore à à à
définir ce qui est sûr si on regarde un
petit peu ce qui se fait à l'échelle
européenne hein parce que c'est c'est là
aussi que ça ça nous donne des
indications justement sur où se situe la
France est-ce que réellement on est très
très dur voire même injuste ou est-ce
qu'on est plutôt plutôt laxiste en
Allemagne c'est 18 mois pour toute
personne qui refusent notamment de
décliner l'identité au Royaume-Uni ça
peut être même illimité on vous garde de
manière illimitée si si on le souhaite
en en centre de rétention administrative
donc ce que ce que veut faire alors à
travers peut-être cet article là et
d'autres le gouvernement et on le sent
c'est de
d'ajuster un petit peu au niveau
européen les règles migratoires
françaises parce que sur les conditions
sur par exemple de langue d'intégration
et cetera la France n ne fait pas partie
des pays les plus exigeants l'Italie
l'Allemagne par exemple sont beaucoup
plus que nous mais mais je reviens
vraiment à la à la question enfin voilà
ou à l'idéologie l'idéologie pardon
djihadiste puisque ce sont les termes
qui ont été employés par plusieurs
membres du du gouvernement c'est c'est
compliqué parce que vous disiez comment
on respecte en est en démocratie si on
respecte l'État de droit est-ce que on
juge quelqu'un avant qu'il ait commis un
acte tout simplement parce que il adhère
à une idéologie il y a des enquêtes
Sébastien Ferjou je crois qu'il faut là
encore distinguer des choses le
djihadisme ça n'est pas l'islamisme donc
ça n'est pas non plus la pratique d'un
islam rigoriste on peut trouver
détestable en terme de cohésion
nationale la pratique de C islam
rigoriste quand il s'inscrit dans un
regard agressif porté sur la société
française c'est si vous considérez que
la société française est impure parce
que elle ne vit pas selon ces règlesl
euh ça peut être détestable pour autant
ça n'est toujours pas du djihadisme et
oui je crois qu'il faut protéger l'État
de droit et que peut-être l'enjeu
premier d'être capable de définir qui
nous sommes parce qu'avant de définir ce
que serait ou devrait être les autres ce
qui par nature sera compliqué alors
après il y a quand même des éléments
concrets respecter l'égalité
hommes-femme par exemple respecter les
enseignements euh qui se passent à
l'école respecter un certain nombre de
règles de civilité dans les entreprises
notamment le problème c'est que là nous
ne sa avons nous avons tellement renoncé
à définir qui nous sommes que même une
entreprise par exemple qui serait
confrontée à une personne qui se
revendique islamiste encore une fois il
ne s'agit pas de djihadisme islamiste
elle peut être condamnée au prudhom ou
autre pour discrimination si elle dit
bah vous voyez bien que ça crée un
problème dans la cohésion de
l'entreprise mais c'est parce que nous
avons cédé sur ce terrainlà nous avons
cédé sur ce terrainlà et je pense que
c'est ce terrain là qu'il nous faut
remuscler et qu'il nous faut en quelque
sorte nous réarmer civiquement pour être
capable de dire en France les valeurs de
la République et les valeurs du contrat
social parce que le contrat social ça
n'est pas la même chose que le vivre
ensemble à partir du moment où on a
commencé à employer le mot de vivre
ensemble on était déjà dans une
dégradation ça ne veut rien dire vivre
ensemble le contrat social c'est quand
même chacun qui met quelque chose et qui
respecte le contrat ça n'est pas juste
la paix par défaut Hervé je vous pose la
même question est-ce que ça vous semble
applicable comment on va pouvoir définir
ce que voilà ce que sont les les valeur
de la République et ce qui est
l'adhésion à une idéologie islamiste non
c'est je pense la même chose là même si
j'ai désaccord avec Monsieur Ferjou je
suis un peu près de son avis mais ce qui
est grave là-dedans c'est l'idée que on
s'oriente vers le délit d'opinion d'une
certaine manière et je voyais hier soir
il y avait un documentaire qui était sur
la montée du du nazisme et surtout
l'antisémitisme en Allemagne et on
voyait bien que dès les premers mois de
33 c'est par là que le le régime nazi a
commencé c'est-à-dire il a créé un dél
d'opinion et il a mis il a créé il a
ouvert le camp d' Chao à ce moment-là et
il a envoyé à peu près
5000 militants communistes et et
socialistes donc c'est très très
dangereux de mettre le doigt dans cette
engrenage j'entends l'argument mais
comment on se protège mieux de ces euh
terroristes terroristes dormant quoi qui
sont sur notre et encore une fois je
peut-être aussi peut-être aussi en étant
capable d'appeler un chat un chat oui il
y a un problème avec enfin un problème
d'intégration en France oui un certain
nombre de musulmans se sont mal intégrés
oui le sentiment d'humiliation est un
des piliers de la culture
arabo-musulmane des gens comme amine
malouf ont écrit des très beaux livres
là-dessus des chercheurs ont écrit
là-dessus depuis les croisades mais ça
n'est pas àodin je vous dis pas juste
pour faire des références historiques
c'est parce que ce sentiment
d'humiliation il est très difficile à
gérer pour la société d'accueil parce
qu'il est à la fois encré dans une
réalité historique il est aussi encré
dans une réalité économique et sociale
aujourd'hui et si nous ne parvenons pas
à maintenir un lien et c'est-à-dire
aussi à maintenir un lien avec tous ceux
des musulmans qui eux ne s'inscrivent
pas dans cette vision islamiste parce
que c'est aussi sur eux qu'il faut
compter c'est aussi sur eux qu'il faut
compter pour maintenir des digs et en
matière de sécurité aussi parce que
jamais nous ne vivons dans un état
policier jamais nous ne pourrons
surveiller tous les gens susceptibles de
devenir djihadistes demain faudra bien
compter aussi sur ceux qui repèent la
radicalisation et qui le repèrent mieux
en général que les familles
souvenez-vous après le Bataclan il y
avait eu un numéro vert il y avait eu
beaucoup de familles qui inquiète avait
elle-même appelé en je pense qu'il va
falloir réfléchir profondément parce que
il va y av avoir aussi probablement du
terrorisme d'une autre nature et je
pense aux écolos et avec cette
association qui était impossible à à
supprimer soulèvement de la terre donc
c'est pas non c'est pas qu'une question
musulmane moi je m'interroge quand même
aussi derrière ces questionsl de Gérald
armanin si c'est pas une manière aussi
de se défausser de défausser sur la
responsabilité de l'État parce que au
lendemain de l'assassinat de Samuel pati
ont été pointé certaines failles dans
des alertes qui avaient été aperçu de
sur la plateforme Pho des choses qui
n'avaient pas à chaque petit bout de la
chaîne était prise en compte et on ne
sait pas évidemment on peut pas réécrire
l'histoire de savoir si on avait pris en
compte ces ces élémentsl ne seraitce que
le soutien du professeur au niveau de
l'établissement si on aurait pu empêcher
ça mais est-ce que c'est pas quelque
part aussi une façon de de repousser sur
les lois cette incapacité à se protéger
contre ces actes terribles quand même
quelque chose é il était extrêmement
surveillé puisque la surveillance
n'était pas seulement une surveillance
sur écoute mais également physique et il
avait d'ailleurs était passé sous en
contrôle donc seulement il y avait pas
d'éléments justement palpable qui
expliquait que oui il allait passer àta
tant qu'il tant qu'il y avait pas de
fait répréhensive on pouvait pas
l'arrêter c'est ça pouit pas l'arrêter
mais en plus en plus de ça on peut pas
dire pour parce que c'est vrai que
parfois docun ont tendance à dire qu'il
y a un fichage s un petit peu large et
qu'on a tendance à mettre beaucoup de
gens ficher S et ne pas pouvoir tous les
surveiller lui il était extrêmement
surveillé il était on ne peut pas dire
là que les services de renseignement non
fait leur travail enfin en tout cas
c'est c'est un jugement un petit peu le
cas dans dans dans l'assassinat de
Samuel Patti il y a eu énormément de
choses et de ont été don il était pas
sur surveillance non mais simplement ce
que je dis c'est qu'il y a peut-être
aussi dans notre capacité à repérer ça
et être bien aligné pour se pour se mais
quce qui
existe- qui existe
enéissement la sœur de la saan d'aras du
terroriste d'araste elle a raconté le
cauchemar qu'elle vivait justement avec
un père et des frères absolument
radicalisé qui lui imposait ainsi qu'à
sa mère une vie absolument épouvantable
qu'est-ce qui existe en France pour les
gens qui sont dans cette situation c'est
quand je vous disais que c'est nous-même
qui devons nous réarmer moralement
civiquement pour être capable de ne pas
fermer les yeux pour être capable
d'arrêter le pas de vague en disant bon
bah tant qu'ils ont pas poignardé
quelqu'un finalement on va croiser les
doigts en espérant que ça n'arrive pas
mais il y a des situations il y a pas
besoin d'arriver à un attentat pour
qu'il y ait des situations qui soient
insoutenables et elle est tout aussi
elle a tout autant le droit de vivre en
France la jeune fille en question
pourquoi la France n'était-elle pas là
pour la protéger elle aussi parce que
c'est pas la seule et c'est pas une
question d'ailleurs de genre j'imagine
qu'il y a des garçons qui peuvent vivre
aussi dans des familles ou dans des
quartiers sous lesquels ils sont soumis
à ça nous avons renoncé nous avons
renoncé ce sont les fameux quartiers
perdus de la République depuis depuis
longtemps autre élément de ce sondage ça
pour Le Figaro autre question et et on
reste toujours sur sur cette proposition
on va dire de du ministre de l'Intérieur
retirer un titre de séjour à un étranger
pour adhésion je le cite à l'idéologie
djihadiste pensez-vous que cette mesure
sera efficace pour lutter contre le
terrorisme 73 % de oui 26 % de non sauf
que Hervé las je reviens à la question
des ooctf des obligations de quitter le
territoire qui sont si difficiles à
appliquer comment ça s'explique ça bah
c'est parce que vous avez nécessité
d'avoir un laisser passer consulaire
autrement dit quand vous voulez expulser
une personne vers son pays de d'origine
ou de
nationalité ce le consulat de ce pays
doit reconnaître cette personne comme
euh de son pays et un grand nombre de
pays euh reconnaissent assez
difficilement et certains très très
difficilement donc on a tenté Macron a
président Macron a tenté à un moment
donné de faire des la rétorsion avec
notamment l'Algérie sur les visas de
façon à ce que l'Algérie accepte plus
facilement de délivrer des laissés
passers consulaire mais il y a pas
l'Algérie seulement la Turquie et là
mettez-vous dans le le le cas de cette
assassin du professeur il faut demander
un laisser passer consulaire à la Russie
puisque l'ingucci est
russi faut voir peut-être que les Russes
l'accorderont mais c'est pour vous dire
la difficulté des choses et c'est sans
doute je dirais dans la question de
l'immigration ça a été dit au au début
sur cette question de des demandes
d'asile c'est sans doute la vraie
question pour l'instant parce que pas
tellement en temps même de niveau de
demande d'asile mais parce que c'est au
niveau des rejets des demandes d'asile
et ces rejets de demandes d'asile la
plupart d'entre elles restent dans les
pays européens et beaucoup d'entre elles
presque toutes d'ailleurs enfin un large
un large nombre d'entre elles parce que
elle ne on ne peut pas obtenir de
laisser passer consulaire pour elle il y
a pas que cela mais c'est un un gros un
gros élément et c'est renforcé par le
fait que les procédure de d'admission à
l'asile prennent du temps donc les
personnes s'installent en France r
par est là et que nous ne sommes pas je
vous dis pas que c'est la solution mais
au moinsons bout des logiques qu'on met
dans le débat public parce que aussi
longtemps qu'on raisonnera et je suis
d'accord avec l'exposé de la situation
qu'a fait monsieur Lebras mais on pour
regarder l'imamusin quand il s'est
sentim mal à l'aise il est parti en
Belgique parce que il y a un autre il
pourrait y avoir une autre voix c'est de
dire aux gens soit vous êtes en
rétention administrative à vitam etnam
aussi longtemps que nous considérons que
nous sommes en situation de guerre parce
que ce sont des mots qu'on emploie que
le Président de la République a pu
emploiler notamment vis-àvis du dis ou
alors vous débrouillez pour trouver un
point un point de chute parce que les
gens qui ont envie d'aller se former à
la radicalité au Pakistan ou en ou en
Syrie ou et cetera ils ont aucun
problème ils ont pas besoin d'avoir un
laisser passer consulaire quand eux ils
souhaitent le faire volontairement ils
arrivent très bien à quitter la France
et aller s'installer auréasen votre
point de vue làdessus quelques mots
rapidement dans la continuité de de ce
qui a été dit en effet les octf ou ITF
c'est les interdictions de territoire
sont difficiles pour un certain nombre
de pays à à appliquer alors on a fait en
effet du du chantage au visa avec un
certain nombre de pays ça a marché
plutôt bien pour certains pays le Maroc
l'Algérie là la Tunisie pose un nouveau
problème c'est à nouveau difficile d'
d'en obtenir si pareil on regarde un peu
que font nos voisins et bien par exemple
l'Allemagne alors l'Allemagne euh je je
cite souvent l'Allemagne parce qu'en
fait l'Allemagne est aussi le pays qui a
beaucoup inspiré ce ce projet de loi
asileimmigration euh l'Allemagne elle
retient moins que nous elle met moins de
personne en centre de rétention
administrative mais elleexulse elle
éloigne davantage notamment parce
qu'elle fait en effet pression
diplomatique sur les visa et aussi sur
l'aide au développement ce que nous on
ne fait pas c'estàd soumettre de l'aide
au développement à ces fameux laisser
passés consulair ouais effectivement
alors on continuer de creuser un peu le
contenu de de de de ce texte et les
concessions que le ministre de
l'Intérieur pourrait faire à à la
majorité sénatorial ici la majorité LR
je propose à Marion delpèche de nous
rejoindre de nouveau sur ce plateau euh
Marion on va rentrer dans le détail de
ces mesures qui seront examinées dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi ici au Sénat à
partir du Sy novembre oui tout à fait un
Thomas en quête d'une majorité Gérald
haranin a présenté son texte comme une
réponse au terrorisme pour séduire la
droite sénatoriale il entend durcir ses
positions avec plusieurs concessions
possibles il se dit tout d'abord
favorable à la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État qui couvre les frais des
étrangers présents en France depuis au
moins 3 mois les sénateurs de droite
souhaite la restreindre au traitement de
maladies graves de douleurs aigu ou de
soins entre autres à la grossesse il a
aussi fait savoir qu'il réfléchissait à
une disposition permettant le retrait du
titre de séjour pour motif d'adhésion à
une idéologie djihadiste radicale
concrètement et bien Bovo donne
l'exemple du cas de quelqu'un qui aurait
dans son téléphone une photo de
décapitation de l'État islamique enfin
évoqué effectivement sur ce plateau
autre exemple tout fait enfin il y a une
autre annonce celle d'allonger et bien
la durée maximale de rétention
administrative des étrangers
de 3 à 18 mois s'ils sont fichers S ou
délinquants alors ajouter de nouvelles
mesures c'est une piste he que n'exclu
pas Muriel Jourda rapporteur du texte et
François Noël buffet président les
républicains de la commission des lois
au Sénat on les écoute c'est déjà
quelque chose qui avait été intégré dans
le travail des rapporteurs et et dans le
travail de la commission les délais qui
nous étent impartis nous avaient pas
permis de faire exactement ce que nous
souhaitions faire parce que c'est assez
technique mais nous nous allons
retravailler c'était déjà prévu donc
au-delà de l'émotion l'immigration c'est
un sujet quand même dont nous sommes
arés depuis un certain temps avec moins
de succès auprès du gouvernement mais je
pense que là nous pouvons peut-être
aboutir oui il y a un point sur lequel
au moins un point sur lequel nous devons
faire bouger les choses c'est ce qu'on
appelle les dispositions de l'article 9
et 10 dans notre jargon qui consiste à
revoir les les
exceptions existante dans le code qui
nous qui empêche de pouvoir expulser des
personnes personnes qui ont qui sont sur
le territoire depuis très longtemps je
ne rentre pas dans les délais ou qui
sont âgés de moins de 13 ans d'ailleurs
et et que pour ce motif on ne peut pas
les renvoyer alors actuellement 489
étrangers en situation irrégulière
inscrit au fichier des personnes
radicalisées sont toujours sur le sol
français Thomas merci beaucoup Marion
Émilie zapski on va faire un peu de
politique sur le le on comprend bien que
pour faire passer ce projet de loi le
ministre Géral armanin est en train de
céder à la droite et l'air mais il y a
un petit risque quand même de de
fracturation le mot est sans doute un
peu fort interne au sein de la majorité
présidentielle vous l'avez un peu évoqué
tout à ou je l' évqué puisque Caroline
janvier donc est assez opposée et elle
menace après la Seu c'est pas la seule
et ça pourrait un petit peu faire du
bruit parce que c'est vrai qu'on a vu
auparavant dans la majorité dès qu'il y
avait des dissensions comme ça c'était
relativement vite calmé mais sur ce
sujet-l je pense qu'il y a des points de
non retour quand on voyait par exemple
sur l'aide médicale de l'état je suis
pas sûr que des députés que certains
députés Renaissance souhaite avancer
là-dessus au-delà même de la
régularisation he des travailleurs sans
papier je pense que ces questions-l ça
peut craquer fortement dans la majorité
ça je saéasen faire jou est-ce que le
ministre joue une un peu de son dessin
politique sur ce sur ce texte d'près
vous ou est-ce qu'il le perçoit comme ça
en tout cas en tout cas lui semble décid
à le faire oui peut-être à regagner un
peu le terrain perdu notamment avec une
rentrée un peu ratée souvenez-vous il
avait promis une rentrée pétaradante et
puis il avait été recadré par Madame
borne et par et par l'Élysée début début
septembre mais je crois que ce qui est
dommageable de toute façon même en terme
de destin politique c'est que on ça fait
partie des choses de gérer évidemment
enfin d'une carrière politique au sens
noble du terme que de gérer les
préoccupations des Français maintenant
quand on est que dans la posture et que
dans l'instrumentalisation parce qu'il
me semble en avoir parlé d'ailleurs sur
votre plateau tomain il y a quelques
temps le problème de cette loi c'est
qu'elle est devenue qu'une question de
posture c'est regardez je suis de droite
parce que je soutiens cette mesure
regardez je suis de gauche parce que je
soutiens je sais pas quoi parce que je
seraai en faveur de la régularisation
des S papiers qui aurait auraient un
travail et ça ne gère en rien la réalité
des problématique de la société
française je crois que ça n'est pas à la
hauteur de ce que de ce que sont les
enjeux non pas que d'immigration parce
que c'est pas l'immigration avec lequel
nous avons véritablement un problème
c'est l'intégration ou bah parmi ces
problématiques on en a pas parlé il y a
quand même l'autre versant de la loi qui
est cette régularisation dans les
métiers t mais oui parce que il y a
rapport du BPI de Nicolas dufourc qui
montre que les plus fortes tensions ce
n'est pas ni dans l'hôtellerie ni dans
la restauration mais c'est dans les
techniciens de l'industrie c'est dans
les ingénieurs de de
fabrication et là il y a une demande il
y a une demande des industriels ils
évitent dans le rapport de trop se
prononcer mais ils font quand même si
vous lisez le rapport assez nettement
pour et le ministre de l'Industrie l'a
dit clairement il a dit Nicolas du FC 6
si on n pas ces régularisations et
peut-être même un peu plus c'est
impensable de se réindustrialiser comme
on le demande on n pas la main d'œuvre
nécessaire et le même problème se pose
d'ailleurs il se pose en Allemagne aussi
il se pose dans plusieurs autres pays
canadienne en
réité r y a un véritable enjeu donc oui
mais Canada un système qui est vraiment
extrêmement différent ouis non mais
d'immigration choisit d'aller chercher
profil qui n'est pas la même chose que
d'essayer de faire rentrer au chospied
des personnes déjà présentes en France
et pas forcément adapté à la réalité du
marché sur cette question de la
régularisation des des travillur sans
papier dans les métiers en tension
Rachel Binas alors effectivement les
premiers secteurs qui nous viennent en
tête c'est hôel restauration et
bâtiments a d'ailleurs sans doute une
par d'hibocrisie générale quand on pense
enfin voilà quand on va dans les
cuisines des grands restaurants dans les
grandes villes enfin des grands des
restaurants dans les grandes villes
françaises ou quand on parle des
chantiers du bâtiment notamment ce des
Jeux Olympiques il y a des il y a des
sans papier en grève là en ce moment sur
l'un des chantiers des Jeux Olympiques
bon donc déjà il y a quand même une
économie française qui a aussi besoin de
ses travailleurs aujourd'hui s je vous
avoue que c'est une confession j'ai
toujours du mal avec cette idéelà qu'on
aurait besoin et qu'on viendrait prendre
on viendrait prendre on viendrait
déplacer et et je dirais pas que c'est
c'est une vision post-coloniale mais on
l'a vu avec par exemple le titre le
titre des médecins des soignants on va
aller chercher les soignants puisque
nous avons besoin de soignants pourquoi
pas mais alors dans ce cas-là en effet
on fait un système à la canadienne ou à
l'allemande avec un système à point en
fonction des compét exct la
mme c'est des hommes et des femmes qui
sont venus en FR en Europe et et à qui
on propose d'avoir des papiers toutit la
même chose exactement c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose or nous on a une
immigration si on compare si on fait une
comparaison avec les pays deocde qui est
assez peu qualifié pour ne pas dire très
peu qualifié qui par exemple pour les
demandeurs d'asile qui obtiennent aussi
l'asile on pense par exemple aux Afghans
qui est une nationalité assez demandeuse
qu' l'obtient la plupart on va dire que
la moyenne d'âge c'est 27 ans et c'est
des hommes très souvent célibataires 27
ans qui ne maîtrisent pas leur langue
maternelle ni en lecture ni en écriture
donc l'apprentissage du français est est
difficile tout ça pour vous dire que la
question du travail c'est aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut apporter à des
personnes quel type de formation est-ce
qu'on en a les moyens les les métiers en
tenstion on ne sait pas trop quel métier
en tension d'ailleurs quelle définition
non mais là ça c'est pas ça n'a pas été
ça n'a pas encore été défini ce n'est
pas clair et dernier point on ne part
pas non plus de zéro en terme de
régularisation par le travail euh en
2021 on en a fait 36000 à cela s'ajoute
la circulaire Vals du 28 novembre 2012
qui nous permet aussi de régulariser les
gens qui travaillent donc je ne dis pas
que c'est suffisant forcément mais on ne
parle pas de zéro et on a les moyens si
on veut aussi de régulariserord ok alors
attendez je je redonner la parole
Sébastien mais vous vouliez intervenir
pour qu'on reste dans dans la thématique
sur sur le le niveau en fait niveau de
formation euh là à nouveau il suffit de
prendre ce que Linc publie chaque année
qui est le mouvement de la population et
il donne le niveau de diplôme des ceux
qui sont entrés dans l'année de ceux qui
ont reçu la carte de séjour dans l'année
les chiffres sont les suivants 51 %
d'entre eux je je veux pas me battre
avec les chiffres il y a
d'autres laisse-mo TER on va laisser le
BR ces chiffres par ils sont les
chiffres c'est pas Mo qui lesent ils
sont dans l'INC donc vous pouvez
critiquer l'INC mais mais je voudrais
mais laissez-moi continuer parce que il
y a 24 % par contre qui n'ont aucun
diplôme c'est le problème un des
problèmes de la formation c'est-à-dire
qu'on a une courbe qu'on appelle à deux
bosses on a à la fois des gens diplômés
et à la fois des gens non diplômés en
plus forte proportion que dans la
population française c'est ça la
situation c'est tout vous pouvez dire à
lins que lins se
trompe je suis responsable de mes propos
pas de votre interprétation du tout que
lin se Tromp PL si vous contestez ce
chiffre c'est que se trompe si vous le
contestez de toute façon par on parle
d'autre chose qu'on parle des gens qui
par définition ne sont pas dans les
statistiques de l'INC parce qu'ils sont
en situation irrégulire sont en tout
monde quand ils sont en situation
régulière mais les les données
européennes montrent que
structurellement les données statista
les données de l'OCDE le montrre aussi
structurellement structurellement la
France fait face à une main d'œuvre et
ça n'exclut pas le fait qu'il y ait
aussi des gens diplômés qui Arve en
France mais structurellement quand on se
compare aux autres pays la France fait
face à par exemple le Royaume-Uni les
gens qui arrivent sont plutôt mieux
formés que la population britannique non
mais que la population britannique
elle-même mais surtout il y a quand même
un raisonnement qui est vicié
c'est-à-dire si ce sont des emplois que
les Français ou les étrangers en
situation régulière ne veulent pas
occuper parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
rationalité économique et sociale parce
que c'est ce que vous disiez enfin dans
quel secteur ça se situe ça se situe
dans des secteurs qui sont compliqués
qui sont difficiles donc quelle est la
logique de faire venir vir des gens qui
vont l'accepter parce qu'ils sont
fraîchement arrivés et puis derrière se
comporteront comme exactement tous les
autres français ou étrangers installés
en France parce que et ils auront raison
de le faire ils considéront qu'ils ont
le droit au même à la même promesse
économique et sociale d'intégration que
les autres je c'est quand même assez
étonnant philosophiquement de voir qu'on
pourrait dire bah finalement il y a des
gens qui sont qui ont l'air bien
disposés à se laisser exploiter bah
faisons les venir et puis après ça
marchera plus temp ce jour-l on
échangera il y a juste un principe de
réalité hein moi je prends le le covid
pendant la période de covid on s'est
rendu compte au niveau de l'agriculture
quiil manquait énormément de bras pour
faire la cueillette non mais c'est c'est
incroyable mais personne pour la
cueillette des fraises les fèves parce
que c'est en effet des activités qui
sont très laborieuses qui sont très
difficiles physiquement et qu'on est
qu'on va chercher temporairement au
Maghreb la plupart du temps de la main
d'œuvre et qui ne pouvait plus venir non
juste une remarque moi j'ai l'impression
que ce texte il veut avec ça en même
temps et vouloir régaler un peu tout le
monde à droite à GAE le texte initial
auelà même de ça on mélange de de du
terrorisme de l'économique c'est un
voilà pour des gesticulations comme vous
l'avez dit en tout cas pour des volontés
de marquer des points un peu à droite ou
voir un peu à extrême droite et à gauche
c'est un Glob bulg quand même assez
important et ça va être difficile de
trouver changement le changement
d'argument de ligne d'argumentation de
Géral armanan moi je le
trouve assez dcheux enfin d'ailleurs je
cherche un mot un peu plus négatif que
ça parce que c'était pas ça l'idée de la
loi immigration l'idée de la loi
immigration c'est cétait de réguler les
flux migratoires et effectivement de
répondre à un certain nombre de besoins
alors même si dans la loi immigration il
y avait l'intention de faciliter certain
ex ça devient même si on essaie dans ce
débat de ne pas retenir que ça mais ça
devient quand même comment se
débarrasser des
deséul et moi je trouve que c'est
dommageable de mélanger les enjeux parce
que ce sont des enjeux qui sont
suffisamment explosifs pour ne pas
finalement perdre sur tous les terrains
en étant pas capable de les considérer
avec sérénité il nous reste allez 2
minutes je vrais vous entendre quand
même sur la l'histoire d'appel d'air euh
parce que c'est ce qui est associé ceux
qui critiquent cet article 3 disent
attention quand on régularise ou qu'on
annonce qu'on va régulariser il y a un
afflux de de de migrants oui ou non bon
les études enfin certain nombre de
travaux ont été faits surtout à propos
des deux deux régularisations massif
serait un grand mot mais il y a eu je
crois 90 92000 et 125000 régularisé pour
à chaque fois 145000 demandes on na pas
vu de monté de l'immigration ni des
soldes migratoires ni des soldes
constatés par l'INC dans les années qui
ont suivi donc grosso modo au fond quand
la seule chose qui marche assez bien
quand vous cherchez à comprendre les
soldes migratoires c'est l'état de
l'économie si vous partez depuis
carrément même 1946 vous avez une sorte
de décalage le sold migratoire commence
à monter à peu près 1 an après que
l'économie ce soit rétablie et que les
taux de croissance sont importants puis
même chose ça baisse 1 an après donc la
question de l'appel d'air ne marche pas
ça n'a pas peut-être que ça se produira
maintenant j'en sais
rien ça ne s'est pas produit les deux
fois précédentes voilà réalité qui est
plus complexe il y a la réalité des
situations enfin des sociétés de départ
et il y a effectivement notre économie
enfin quand on regarde aux États-Unis
Donald Trump il n'a rien fait il a pas
construit son mur simplement le simple
fait de ne pas se montrer accueillant en
fait que les gens ne sont pas venus et
même chose avec le Danemark donc pour
partie le signal qui est envoyé par les
pays européens ou les pays occidentx de
manière générale il a un impact dans les
après ça n'est pas un impact absolu
parce que ça dépend aussi de la
situation économique et sociale ou de
guerre des pays de départ donc c'est pas
exclusif l'un de l'autre mais quand même
dire nous ne souhaitons plus accueillir
des gens c'est entendu allez on termine
là-dessus merci beaucoup rachelas on
vous lit évidemment dans le magazine
Marianne jeansébastien Ferjou on renvoie
au site Atlantico merci Hervé Lebas
d'être venu participer à ce débat Émilie
à très bientôt sur ce plateau voilà
c'est la fin de ce numéro de sens public
merci à toutes et à tous de votre
fidélité je vous dis à lundi sur public
sénna et notez que demain dans sa
matinale Oriane monsini reçoit Patrick
Pelou le président de l'Association des
médecins urgentistes de France je vous
souhaite une belle
[Musique]
soirée